May 11th 2015 the GOI one satellite
captures a strange marking across the
arid plains of Bolivia what would create
a dark streak like that out in the
desert
there's no way to relate the darkened in
areas to any phenomenon that I can think
of the answer may lie in the mining
history of mineral-rich Bolivia and
neighboring Chile the Atacama Desert is
very dry rocky area almost no plant
growth very few animals there is however
some industrial development there
because of the minerals that exist the
region from the Atacama Desert to the
Bolivian Plains was once famous for its
wealth of tin copper silver and nitrate
reserves there is a long history of
mining in the Atacama starting with
exploitation of the nitrate deposits in
the early part of the nineteenth century
I understand that much of the gunpowder
used by the British and allied forces in
World War one that was manufactured with
nitrate from the Atacama in the late
1800s a vast network of railroads was
built to support the region's booming
mining industry
but in the 1930s disaster struck as the
Great Depression wiped out demand the
trains were left to rot in the desert
using image enhancement the identity of
the dark mark visible from space is
finally revealed
what I am seeing is what I would call a
train graveyard it is hundreds of trains
there just littering the earth in this
designated cemetery
these are the trains that built the
Bolivian Wild West
you